it's not a good idea
erase our history and identity
to send a message to others
but no Muslim
No doctor would have erased his story
because respect
if we don't respect it ourselves
the others
will never respect the Europeans
it's not secularism
it's stupidity
secularism is something else
I believe in secularism
secularism is not erasing history
it is not to erase the identity
no one is obliged
to say that I am a Christian
we are Christians
because our part
Christian
we can't give up our identity
that's why
I am really disappointed
for this image
I hope they will change
things in France
because as I said we can't change history
the cross is there you can't erase it in a picture
it is not the photo that changes the history of France
the history of Europe